streitpunkt schnelltests bund und länder
geben sich gegenseitig die schuld am
schleppenden start öffnung mit corona
auflagen der einzelhandel in mehreren
bundesländern bereitet sich auf die
kundschaft vor ja zum verhüllungsverbot
knappe mehrheit der schweizer stimmt für
den umstrittenen vorstoß
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster
wir kommen bei unseren
nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag den
sport gibt es in kürze von 10 fuß schon
genannt ab morgen gilt es das recht auf
den einen kostenlosen corona test pro
woche
doch so wie es aussieht wird das wohl
nicht überall klappen und zur kritik
über fehlenden impfstoff kommt jetzt
auch noch die klage über zu wenige
schnelltests einstecken muss sie wieder
vor allem gesundheitsminister sparen
der aber wehrt sich und zeigt mit dem
finger auf die länder
florian a ein kostenloser corona
schnelltest im probebetrieb bieten sie
das im schleswig-holsteinischen
rendsburg seit wochen
doch bevor der service für alle starten
soll hat der chef des örtlichen
lagezentrums mehr fragen als antworten
wir brauchen auf jeden fall klare
angaben woher das personal kommt welche
institutionen jetzt genau beauftragt
werden wer das macht auch wie die tests
abgerechnet werden ein schnelltest für
jeden pro woche dass dieses versprechen
ab morgen noch nicht überall eingehalten
werden kann
dafür wird in der politik kurz vor
wichtigen landtagswahlen ein schuldiger
gesucht und vom politischen konkurrenten
auch gefunden
wir hatten die zusage und da ist der
bundesgesundheitsminister 500 millionen
tests vertraglich vereinbart hat das ist
so nicht eingetreten überraschender
gegenwind für sparen auch aus der
schwesterpartei csu
man kann nicht sagt der generalsekretär
die verantwortung beim testen auf die
länder schieben und sich selbst für
komplett unzuständig erklären
der so gescholtene im digitalen
landtagswahlkampf unterwegs wiederum
bittet um etwas geduld
die schnellste mehr als genug verfügbar
die strukturen entstehen sie werde noch
nicht überall am montag gleich
vollständig da sein der bei präsentiert
die berliner gesundheitssenatorin spd am
nachmittag eines von 16 testzentren der
stadt in dem ab morgen schnell getestet
wird auch wenn nicht alle fragen geklärt
sind
solange es kein einheitliches konzept
dazu gibt wer hat eine berechtigung wie
wird es nachgewiesen öffnen wir jetzt
einfach unsere testzentren für die
berlinerinnen und berliner
ein schnelltest pro woche groß sind die
hoffnungen fast ebenso große noch die
zweifel an der schnellen
umsetzung die masken affäre sorgt weiter
für unruhe und empörung in der union
nach dem csu-abgeordneten nüßlein hat
jetzt auch der cdu-abgeordnete löbel
seinen rückzug aus der politik
angekündigt
beide sollen sechsstellige provisionen
für die vermittlung von masken
geschäften kassiert haben führende
unions politiker innen forderten möbel
und nüßlein müssten ihre mandate sofort
niederlegen und nicht erst in den
nächsten monaten mehr dazu gleich im
anschluss in berlin direkt
schauen wir auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen in deutschland
das robert koch institut meldet 8103
neue infektionen innerhalb eines tages
das sind 213 mehr als am vergangenen
sonntag
außerdem kamen 96 weitere todesfälle
dazu die sieben tage incidents steigt
ebenfalls etwas auf nun 66 1 trotz
leicht steigender zahlen morgen ist es
soweit nach wochen der einschränkungen
wird in einigen bereichen wieder
gelockert vor allem beim einzelhandel so
dürfen zum beispiel buchhandlungen
blumenläden und gartenmärkte wieder
öffnen
weitere lockerungen hängen von der
lokalen infektions lager neben
rheinland-pfalz hat schleswig holstein
derzeit die niedrigste sieben tage
instituts von dort berichtet tanner
hebestreit soviel wochenendarbeit war in
husums modehaus cj schmidt schon lange
nicht mehr
sie bereiten alles vor damit die
kundschaft am morgen endlich wieder
selbst stöbern kann schleswig holstein
macht die läden auf die einzelhändler
haben der politik erheblich druck
gemacht wir haben natürlich versucht der
strategie der vielen nadelstiche mit den
argumenten die wirklich auch auf unserer
seite sind der der politik zu zeigen
wir bestrafen hier die falschen der
schaden der entstanden ist es immens
die infektions lage hier im norden dass
bis auf wenige ausnahmen so niedrig dass
die landesregierung die beschränkungen
lockert und auch tierparks schon vor
tagen wieder geöffnet hat wir haben
guten zulauf das sieht man ja auch heute
jetzt am wochenende es ist auch hinter
mir ein bisschen betrieb das ist sehr
erfreulich und sehr sehr erleichtern war
das erste mal jetzt seit sehr langer
zeit auch wieder geld reinkommt und das
war jetzt auch wirklich dringend nötig
muss man ganz ehrlich sagen
auf beiden seiten der zäune ist die
begeisterung über die lang ersehnte
abwechslung groß dass aber morgen auch
geschäfte wieder öffnen stößt bei den
zweibeinern hier auf geteiltes echo
trainiert auf allen bundesländern wieder
alle leute herkommen soll das hier
wieder auf nadal ist ich finde das
risiko ein verzogener ja ich freue mich
darauf und hoffe dass das dann auch
nicht wieder zurück geht zurück da hin
dass ihre läden nur abholt stationen
sind möchte kein einzelhändler
sie hoffen dass ab morgen die kunden
kommen
zum abschluss seiner irak reise hat
papst franziskus in erbil eine messe vor
tausenden gläubigen gefeiert
dabei warnte er vor der versuchung rache
zu nehmen
erbil war für viele christen ein
zufluchtsort als die terror miliz es in
der region mehrere städte einnahmen
franziskus ist der erste papst der den
irak besucht
in der schweiz soll es künftig ein
verhüllungsverbot in der öffentlichkeit
geben
in einer volksabstimmung bekam der
vorstoß von islamkritikern eine
hauchdünne mehrheit
gegner und gegnerinnen der kampagne und
die regierung warnten es gebe kaum
vollverschleierte frauen in der schweiz
und wenn dann seien sie oft wohlhabende
touristinnen aus den golfstaaten
in europa ist die vollverschleierung in
der öffentlichkeit bereits in fünf
ländern verboten
petra otto berichtet
sie müssen die verfassung ändern ein
verhüllungsverbot hinzufügen
51 prozent der schweizerinnen und
schweizer haben sich dafür heute
ausgesprochen in einer volksabstimmung
frei sein heißt sein gesicht zeigen zu
können die würde der frau zu
respektieren deshalb verstehe ich mich
die menschen die frauen einsperren
wollen hinter schleiern die sonst
konservativ denkende svp zeigt sich bei
dieser initiative als frauen rechts
partei parlament und bundesrat dagegen
sagen nein zum verhüllungsverbot es gebe
kaum 30 in der schweiz lebende frauen
die burka tragen überflüssig dieses
gesetz das ist wirklich eine
demagogische anwendung des rechts auf
volksabstimmung und deshalb verurteilen
wir dass das echte eine ganze gruppe an
menschen die sonst sehr gut integriert
ist bei uns in der schweiz die burka
debatte sie dreht sich nur vordergründig
um kleidung eher um rassismus und
terrorismus um frauenunterdrückung und
religionsfreiheit
das verbot trifft vor allem
urlauberinnen aus dem arabischen raum
deshalb war die tourismusbranche strikt
gegen die initiative der theater
intendant christian stückl ist mit der
buber rosenzweig medaille ausgezeichnet
worden für sein engagement gegen
antisemitismus stückl habe als regisseur
die oberammergauer passionsspiele
reformiert und von ihrem
judenfeindlichen charakter befreit so
die jury die über rosenzweig medaille
wird seit 1968 zum auftakt der woche der
brüderlichkeit verdienen von den
gesellschaften der christlich-jüdischen
zusammenarbeit und jetzt zum sonntag
sport mit sven voss die nordische ski wm
in oberstdorf ging heute mit einem eklat
zu ende im langlauf rennen über 50
kilometer kam es im zielsprint zu einer
rempelei und anschließender
disqualifikation von weltmeister klar
das norwegisch russische ski langlauf
duell ist um ein kapitel reicher
auf der zielgeraden kommt es zur
kollision zwischen dem bis dahin
führenden russen alexander ball schulen
auf mit der startnummer 1 und ging es
neben ihm den norweger johannes klar
nach protest einlegung disqualifizierte
die jury den norweger der sich nur eine
stunde als sieger fühlen durfte
ein bei der siegerehrung sichtlich
genervte ball schulhof musste mit einer
freudlosen silbermedaille vorlieb nehmen
während sich der norweger emil version
über gold und sein landsmann simon hopf
stadt krüger über bronze freuen konnten
zum fussball im ersten sonntagsspiel
trennten sich köln und bremen eins zu
eins unentschieden der fc bleibt damit
auf platz 14 werder auf dem zwölften und
gerade eben wurden die halbfinals im dfb
pokal ausgelost der sieger zwischen jahn
regensburg und werder bremen trifft auf
rb leipzig borussia dortmund mit
heimrecht gegen den zweitligisten noch
holstein kiel und zum abschluss der
leichtathletik hallen em in polen gewann
drei springer max hess die
bronzemedaille mit einer weite von 17,01
metern
insgesamt freut sich der dlv über sechs
medaillen weltmeisterin malaika me
hamburg verpasste im weitsprung gold
denkbar knapp die miene von miami
hamburg war vielsagend die weitsprung
weltmeisterin liegt mit sechs meter 88
aus dem dritten versuch bis zum letzten
durchgang in führung
dann wird sie von der ukrainerin maria
beck romantschuk mit 692 aber doch noch
von der spitze verdrängt
ganz anders die situation bei
dreispringerin neele eckhardt ihre
bronzemedaille mit persönlicher
bestleistung von 14 meter 52 ist gold
wert sie liegt damit nur einen
zentimeter hinter der portugiesischen
siegerin patricia mona
und jetzt startet die freiluftsaison
irgendwie ja danke sven und wir werfen
für die freiluftsaison noch ein blick
auf das wetter morgen im nordosten und
süden viel sonne sonst dichte wolken mit
einzelnen regen oder schneeregenschauer
zwei bis zehn grad so viel von uns für
den moment wir freuen uns dass sie dabei
waren
im heute-journal begrüßt sie claus
kleber zur gewohnten zeit und morgen
übernimmt hier barbara hellwig wir
wünschen noch einen entspannten sonntag